[Music]
we're also publishing a book by Bruce
deal called trust first as you know
Bruce runs an organization called City
of Refuge in Atlanta Georgia and he I
don't know how to put it he saves people
to put it mildly drug addicts and
hookers and all these people and he
takes in the street and he gives them a
second chance and he believes in them
and when you and I met Bruce I think we
were the whole room witness it was
enamored with him because Bruce does
something that I think few of us have
the courage to do which he he he gives
people extreme trust he takes somebody
who the rest of society would say is
unworthy of our trust and he trusts them
as if they were old friends or family
and what he has learned is that when you
take the risk to trust people they rise
to the occasion and they are able to
transform their lives they're able to
transform their path and to one that is
more positive for them and those around
them and though it is a remarkable story
about trust and what Bruce is doing I
the the it's an extreme version of the
lesson I think we could all learn I
think few people and I don't think we
would ever recommend for anybody to
trust the way Bruce trusts I think that
that's a whole another order of trust
but if we could learn to trust better
than we do now to take the risk to trust
people more than we do to learn from
Bruce's example I think it makes for
better organizations and it makes from
better collaboration you know better
work environments better cultures better
society better friendships talk about
inspiring
[Music]